camera comparison on one side I've got
an iPhone 7 plus on the other side I've
got the Sony
a6000 with a Carl ice 24 mm 1.8 aperture
lens open all the way so right now I bet
if I stand back here you know with a lot
of light they probably look pretty
comparable in video quality nice colors
lots of detail both full HD Etc the
different
you'll notice in this lighting is that
the
Sony uh you get this nice what they call
Bouquet which uh I'm in Focus
background's I hope it's pronounced
bouquet it might be
boka uh but the background's out of
focus I'm in
focus focuses in the
background it'll focus on me uh iPhone 7
won't do that nearly as much this is
Optics and it's because on the Sony
there's a big lens and a big sensor size
of my thumb
and the way the light goes through the
lens and hits a sensor if the aperture
is open so the lens is open really big
then automatically uh just because of
Optics whatever's in Focus will be sharp
everything else will be blurry iPhone
has a tiny little lens tiny little
sensor so that doesn't happen naturally
with the iPhone 7 plus like some of
these other new phones it's got two
little cameras and then digitally you
can fake bouquet in photographs so I bet
in another year or two uh it'll be able
to do it with a video so it's really
coming on phones but for now the only
way to get that nice
bouquet is actually with a big sensor
and a big
lens we've got a three-way comparison so
you guys stand close
together so over here we have the iPhone
a6000 in the middle and then the Sony
a7s2
over there now what I'm expecting is
that you're going to see a big
difference between them um how big I
don't know um but I
imagine there definitely going to be a
difference um and we'll know
soon oops almost into the river so here
I'll just do uh I'll try to do a
hyperloop with these I wish there was
more waist on the end
Tada okay so when I put these side by
side we'll be able to see how much of a
differences there is I'm expecting that
in the low light the iPhone won't do as
well but you never
[Music]
know for
come
[Music]